[Musique]
cela n'a pas été simple de parvenir
jusqu'à vous songez qu'en 18 mois de
campagne électorale
j'ai eu droit à une minute de télévision
c'était en octobre 64 et le général de
gaulle était en amérique du sud
quand il est rentré il a fait savoir
sèchement qu'il se réservait le monopole
de la parole
c'est ainsi que j'ai été amené à aller
vers le peuple français afin de suppléer
la carence des moyens modernes
d'information qui quoique payée par tout
le monde
mme été refusée me voici candidat à la
présidence de la république et il nous
appartient de parler de politique mais
voyez vous il y a deux manières de
parler de politique
la première c'est à hauteur de l'état
des doctrines des partis et la seconde
c'était la hauteur de l'individu de
l'homme de la femme de leur bonheur
je suis avocat j'ai 38 ans de pratique
de mon métier qui m'a rendu sensible
avant tout à l'injustice et cette
injustice
elle s'étale tous les jours dans les
moindres faits divers je prends
l'exemple suivant une bonne
économiquement faibles est morte de
froid à paris à sharon comment ton
mourir de froid
en dise le 163 à paris inacceptable
voici ceux là c'est dans la meuse à un
petit commerçant âgé saisi poursuivi par
le fils de manière impitoyable et la
veille du jour où le solde de ses biens
va disparaître il se pend inacceptable
il admission et voici un enfant dévorer
bharara dans une cave où il habitait
pauvre bébé avec 10 de ses frères et
soeurs et les parents depuis huit ans
attendait un autre logement de cette
cave inadmissible et cependant le fait
divers pinces sans jamais réussir à
émouvoir la majesté des pouvoirs publics
et leur suprême indifférence à l'égard
de l'injustice et puis voyez vous j'ai
vécu un drame
un vrai drame qui celui là est le comble
de l'injustice
c'était en 1962 j'avais défendu devant
une juridiction d'exception
un jeune pieds noirs qui avait 27 ans il
avait défendu sa province comme un
breton un provençal ou un béarnais
aurait défendu la sienne si elle avait
été attaquée il fut condamné à la peine
de mort et après j'attendais la
convocation
le jeu devait recevoir du chef de l'état
vous savez un essai d'un condamné à mort
n'attend rien d'autre que l'exercice de
ce pouvoir merveilleux que l'on appelle
le droit de grâce
et depuis milan le défenseur est appelée
à pousser le dernier cri a lancé le
dernier apple a présenté les derniers
arguments
c'est là où réside la chance pour un
homme de conserver la vie et la
convocation voyez vous n'arrivez pas ça
ne m'étonnerait pas plus que mon jeune
pieds noirs avaient été condamnés à mort
et ses chefs ne l'avait pas été
un soir
j'apprends que sans avoir été convoqué
sans avoir pu présenter la requête
c'est pour le lendemain alors dans la
nuit on réveille le garde des sceaux on
lui dit mais c'est impossible on va tuer
un homme alors que son avocat n'a pas
été reçue par le chef de l'état et le
garde des sceaux répond ce n'est pas une
loi
c'est un usage seulement 1,6 voyez vous
un homme est mort parce que le chef de
l'état ne veut pas envie de recevoir son
avocat il est mort dans la splendeur
d'un matin de juin ou touchantes la joie
dur cela c'est le comble de l'injustice
alors j'ai été candidat et j'ai été
candidat mais pour que toutes ces
victimes des injustices sociales des
injustices familiale fiscale et de
l'injustice suprême également tous
ces victimes ne reste pas sans porte
parole et puis chemin faisant
ayant décidé d'être candidat j'ai fait
et vous le savez bien
j'ai fait seul mon métier de candidats
et à la pas d'eau j'ai parlé à 550 mille
d'entre vous afin d'informer afin de
démystifier
c'est un grand effort croyez moi et ce
moment me voici devant vous vais très
bien et je ne suis pas fatiguée parce
que j'appartiens à une race solives et
ferme mon père
à 88 ans il ya trois mois seulement
qu'il a abandonné la médecine et il
conduit toujours sa voiture j'avais bien
et je suis prêt à vous informer
malheureusement malheureusement ça ne va
pas être simple parce que vous le savez
il existe une censure préalable
ce que je vous dis et enregistré d'abord
villon voir s'il n'y a pas trop
d'égratignures à l'égard du prince
et après mais après seulement on vous
donne à connaître mon propos comme celui
des autres tant 10 heures moi j'avais
pensé au meilleur moyen de vous informer
profondément en vous intéressant jamais
pensé projeté quelques séquences d'un
film que j'ai fait c'est un très bon
film il ya deux acteurs de gaulle et moi
et ce film est proposé d'ailleurs
d'actualité comme monté par mois
c'est bien ce film à inquiéter le
pouvoir
bien qu'il s'agisse d'actualité qui
était vu par tout le monde qui marche
comme vous le savez dans sa vie de
gaulle a dit tout et puis le contraire
de tout alors quand on juxtapose les
actualités cinématographiques au cours
du septennat on en obtient des effets
extraordinaires
c'est pourquoi ils n'ont pas voulu vous
pourrez le voir quand même mais dans des
petites séances de projection privée pas
ici s'est défendu puis j'avais pensé
également c'était intéressant faire vous
savez une table ronde seulement une
vraie ta blonde et j'aurais invité le
journaliste du figaro celui de
l'humanité celui de laurent celui de
deux grands journaux de province et même
celui de la nation oui ça vous me direz
que vous connaissez pas c'est vrai la
nation
c'est le journal de l'ue nerfs c'est
elle c'est vous dire que c'est le
journal que personne ne lit nous en
sommes d'accord eh bien ça aussi c'est
défendu alors j'ai pensé ce qui est
naturel que le dialogue était ceux qui
informent le mieux le caractère
contradictoire d'un débat c'est pourquoi
j'ai invité de gaulle à venir devant les
caméras de la télévision un participer à
un débat contradictoire avec moi vous
verrez la date pour laquelle cette
invitation a été faite ce soir là il
viendra où il viendra pas mais s'il
vient ce sera le grand débat
contradictoire est nécessaire que la
france attend en attendant écrivez-moi
19 boulevard de sébastopol
écrivez moi faites moi part de vos
suggestions de vos critiques afin que
dans les émissions qui viennent je
puisse vous informer
encore beaucoup plus complètement est
beaucoup mieux
tv 19 boulevard sébastopol paris et
alors là dans les émissions qui vont
venir et notamment dans la prochaine
dont vous trouverez l'heure dès le jour
dans les journaux ce m'efforcerai de
satisfaire votre curiosité je vous dirai
ce que personne ne vous dira à condition
bien entendu que dame censure me laisse
faire mais c'est laura intérêt à me
laisser faire parce que ce peuple
enfin a besoin d'être informé sur le
bilan de ce régime que je combats et sur
les solutions d'avenir que je préconise
voyez-vous aucun programme quel qu'il
soit ne sera pris au sérieux si les
moyens de le réaliser ne sont pas
présentés en même temps qu'on les nonces
c'est ce que je m'efforcerai de faire
alors
à très bientôt à après demain ou lundi
je crois bon ce premier contact merci et
bon soir
[Musique]